holy bunco's kids look out
the keep it moving tour is adding new
dates
we're coming to a city near you come and
see us
some stand-up and we play ayg at the end
of the show
with the crowd we answer your garbage
questions
we've got some trash so far but i know
i know there's deeper garbage out there
around the country
oh yeah so come on out and see us kippy
tell them what they need to know oh baby
we're
all over the place uh providence rhode
island august 11th boston massachusetts
august 12th
new brunswick new jersey august 25th
down tomatoes
timonium maryland magooby's august 26th
couple of crabs and we're going to tejas
baby
uh september 21st we'll be in san
antonio texas september 22nd we'll be in
houston texas
september 23rd through the 25th austin
texas for the moon tower comedy festival
and i ain't done yet august 26 will be
at
four dallas fort worth texas what then
we're bringing it back
to long island baby what in all uh
september 30th
and then we're coming home the boys are
the chickens are coming home to roost
baby
october 27th we're going to be in
philadelphia pennsylvania and then back
down to tejas
uh november 5th through the 7th for
skankfest south get those tickets the
link will be in the description
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage goddammit sure is
[ __ ] it's a little show we sit down
with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they grow up to be
competing or if they're just big old
pieces of trash
i'm your host dave trolley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
antony's basement
yeah i saw some christmas lights going
up in the back patio outside
and i saw a fresh tray
of jello shots in the fridge so
we're gonna have to make ourselves
scarce tonight is it somebody's birthday
or something i don't know what it is
she's having some of the girls over
and this and that they were talking
about getting a mail stripper so it
might not be anything we want to be
about you available stripping at a
christmas in july party sign me up dude
i mean i'm all for a male stripper but
not around those bozos yeah
you know her and the girls getting
cigarette burns on the guy
nickels at this poor bastard yeah don't
be a [ __ ]
come on get over here let me see your
[ __ ]
i think that rogue bumps going to her
head so we got to uh go to a movie or
something like that and just you know
just to get out of the house we don't
want to be around for no no
come back maybe take a pee come back
late night and see
see you see you still hanging around
he still wants to party late night see
if there's still any onion dip left yeah
i'm not here for the matinee
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table it's a family episode
just us today gang just the boys we're
locking the doors we're turning down the
blinds we're taking the night off
it's just the gang the way we like it
because we love you
give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are
true the roof true the [ __ ] roof and
then patreon.com you heard it once you
heard it twice
everything nice cooking patreon.com you
got bonus episodes ayg
you get the smash hit of the year hard
feelings man that's
going to con next year the pod james con
film festival yeah yeah now we're not
going to france this one's at newark
the scotch first annual filter
reruns the entourage still pretty good
though just the fifth season or whatever
um just just the episodes he's in
guys uh patreon.com you sign up your
bonus episodes ayg
uh episodes of hard feelings and we
every month we play
a live stream with we play ayg with the
top tier listeners
top tier patrons it's a good [ __ ]
time get involved also a live show
come out see a [ __ ] live show plenty
of opportunities
opportunities to come hang at the live
show the live show's a little bit of
stand up then we play we take questions
from the audience to close out the show
it's a great [ __ ]
having a good time and having a nice
shout out to our producer
extraordinaire who's that it's kind of
like our little brother around here yeah
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen
so so insulting he didn't like that the
little brother around here with a bigger
dick
appears for the most part stop dressing
like you're about to cut the lawn
all right yeah take the [ __ ] wrist
rocket out of your back pocket jimmy
all right how you feeling get yourself a
pair of trousers all right
go to work your long hair all hairy legs
your legs are all hairy you you have leg
hair like that not like that that's like
that looks like you've seen they got wet
and you rolled around in a barber shop
it's like a robin williams yeah that's
that's a tough look you shouldn't have
thigh hair that thick
yeah it's tough look yeah i got i'm
patchy i got nothing
really oh it's bad no like there's a few
things on you that are good though can
we
shoot you straight there uh yeah besides
the hammer you gotta go said that you
got to go ahead of hair i got a good
head of hair
good eyes that's about it my
feet aren't that bad to be honest with
you what size of those eyes let me check
the skin tags
[Laughter]
skin tags man i hate them
skin tags and i'm getting like uh it's
from the pre-diabetes
it's uh like a ring around my neck it's
a dark ring around my neck yeah i've
seen
it yeah that's a tough look on a fat guy
yeah yeah it looks like the back of my
head's eating the back of my head
oh i've seen it yeah i've seen it looks
like it looks like you bronzed that part
of your neck
anywho i'm doing great by the way
hey you look good buddy yeah yeah yeah
uh real quick
uh go follow the ru garbage instagram
page please
unlock we unlock the swipe up feature at
10k we're like 100 people away go make
us do it yeah
swipe it up now can i swipe up when i
share it
no really really so i got no swipe up
capability
because you know
the fact that i wouldn't give him the
login to the instagram
were you around for that was that
pre-tov i might have been pre-toby
that almost said that almost ended the
pod do you remember that you called me
at like 7 a.m one morning
give me the password the codes give me
the pay i want to respond to comments
because you don't always share
the stories i think i'm doing a pretty
good job you're doing okay yeah you on
the other hand
you're doing all right turn you in turn
you in and get two five dances
two five dances and another mcmuffin i'm
worth a nickel in michigan
wait still i'm going to refund you get
my deposit back on this guy
gang a [ __ ] family yep we're going to
be asking answering your questions as
you know when you sign up for the old
patreon
um we'll ask your questions on the air
yeah got a bunch of them got a bunch of
them trying to get through them trying
to get through a couple of bags i love
you
i also pulled a couple from that
facebook group because that facebook
group's cooking
wow let's let's [ __ ] let's that was
very yanny i just was i got him i just
[ __ ]
and you hit you hit chris d with the
wild that's history
uh yeah we're like opening franchises
we're cooking all over the place yeah
the the facebook's cooking that facebook
group is something that's
funny man yeah yeah it's a good time so
check that out
check that out too while you're [ __ ]
at it dawg um all right let me just
[ __ ] hop
in what do you want to do let's get
through some questions i i will oh yes
this just popped into my head too i
forgot i i don't know how garbage this
is but it's making me think i got
worms i got we got mice i got a mouse
and a house
jesus which have we never on the sixth
floor too that thing's taking the
[ __ ] elevator every day
i don't know how he's getting in the
[ __ ] building it's got a skull cap
and a grappling hook who's buzzing this
guy in god damn [ __ ] stuart little
over there
every other i think is what happened
they were on the other floors
we never had them we never had an issue
on the sixth floor you know every dirt
bag that has mice or bugs
that we've never had i'm telling you
you're trash
they don't last that long the goldfish
they go quick shout out to the
pepperidge farm company
see i thought regular goldfish yeah
this guy's in left field with a hockey
stick how long have you had him
because i i i i'm an expert in pest
control
you name it i've had it he's been a pest
his whole life
out of control i lived with the family
for eight months they couldn't get rid
of me
i've been with you for 10 years glue
traps all over my head
i tell you what those glute chaps man i
don't like this is just a humane foley
trap i have you in right now
you put some peanut butter in above
ground pool you catch a bully
[Laughter]
um i don't the other apartments
we have friends uh like throughout the
building and they've had them we never
had them
and uh they've gotten rid of them so i
think
a lot of people that had them are people
[ __ ] they gave me your address yeah
they just pushed them into our like i
think other people who had them
[ __ ] got rid of them or scared them
away and now they're just like
descending upon [ __ ]
upon my apartment do you know where
they're coming from is there a hole
anywhere
uh no i mean yeah we just got that
little half circle in the front door to
let them in i don't know
maybe that's where they're coming in oh
he's got a sombrero um no
i don't yeah there's no visual she said
the lady said she saw when we were in
ohio last week
she said she saw one she's like i saw
one who's the lady oh your wife
the [ __ ] you said the lady though i felt
like there was a lady staying at your
house while you guys were away
i don't know what's what i don't know
what you two get up to up there that's
more probable the lady is my wife or the
lady is a lady i'm paying to stay
and i'm
[Laughter]
that is the that's on your tombstone
yeah and i'm glad you are accepting that
more and more you're accepting the fact
that you are you used to fight me on it
now you're going yeah maybe i am crazy
let's keep moving and i love that
straight crazy baby that's your first
album straight crazy baby
straight out of crazy now back to this
my situation you have going on kevin
i listen pinhead you have uh you have
the i don't like this
you have them straight and throw water
at you dude
it's not holy water is it
clean the back of your neck off okay
they said apple cider vinegar
that's what you want to do barbecue
sauce
yeah let me just try a wet nap fatty
um what you could have pipes do you do
you have different do you have any
no water in the whole building no do you
have steam pipes in your building
i'm sorry in your apartment i'm going
somewhere with this
yeah now at the base of that is there a
coupling yeah yeah
is is there any hole in there anything
no it's covered yeah
everything's covered it's like a thing
called it begins with an f i forget but
yeah
flange far sir no far sir
you don't know yeah okay um i would
check all you got to check all that [ __ ]
well they stuff them with brillo pads
yeah last man standing leaves and it
ain't i ain't going okay
yeah dude foley naked with a headlamp
work gloves and a [ __ ] spatula yeah
going after them why do i gotta be naked
because you're a freak well sexual
fantasy um
sexualize me but the other night i was
laying uh wait what what
go ahead you're finding poop everywhere
no no
uh so she said she saw that was like a
week ago and i'm like so i want one
mouse yeah she goes i saw a mouse run in
the hallway
and i'm like all right maybe he was
passed because we don't i've never seen
droppings no nothing no
he's pissing through i don't know i mean
like they're not either
they're at it do we there's no sign that
they're living there i'm not saying i'm
not finding droppings or anything that
they didn't unpack their bags no mail
whose water bill is this who's ordering
amazon who's ordering cheese via
amazon big wheel of parmesan
[Laughter]
that's good stuff no um
but you're like yeah so i've seen no
indication other than she said she's
seen one i'm checking the drawer you
check everything right
um nothing so then the other night i'm
and i kind of forgotten about it because
i'm also like
this isn't an issue i'm not seeing them
i'm not seeing droppings whatever
if you have one that's they're cute well
the other night i was
uh but then i'm thinking it's like it's
it's maybe like
1 30 in the morning i'm in the kitchen
and i think i see one but i don't
i'm going there's no way i'm like i
think i've made that up in my head this
guy's living in your head rent-free oh
yeah dude i'm i got [ __ ]
it's like mouse trap going on in my
[ __ ] head uh i love mousetrap
so there was another one called flying
finnegans
but
[Laughter]
um 1 30 in the morning you're in the
kitchen what are you getting a little
late night snack fatty yeah what was i
doing in there yeah nothing good
huh i might have been clean it might
have just been putting some stuff away
because i'm worried i forgot why i'm 30
yeah i mean i'm not like doing the
dishes but like if there was like
anything
you know i don't know just straightening
the counter me wipe i think i was wiping
down the counter because in my head i'm
like oh
there might be a [ __ ] and now i'm
thinking about you keep any food on the
counter
no any food on top of the refrigerator
uh maybe some
produce like our produce produce on top
of the fridge
okay you know um do mice like onions
because if they do we got a problem i
bought them in bulk
fully still i'll tell you that
so i think i see him i'm going like but
they get my head i go i think i just
like made that up because like he where
i thought he was running i would have
saw
like he'd i think i just made up it in
my head like i just whatever
so then two nights later this is like
two nights ago last night whatever it
was
i'm laying on there the tv turn on
garage door opens up
i'm laying in bed i'm not i'm on the
couch my wife's like i'm going to bed
i'm laying on the couch watching
comedians and cars
getting coffee you know what i mean
hanging out shout out to norman mcdonald
that's hotter than a three dollar pistol
good line there norm and you're watching
on that computer on this computer no tv
no tv okay mouse took it
yeah he claims now do you lay and put it
on your like belly
no i'll lay on the couch i don't know
why we're getting into this
it's just strange i also i understand i
also don't think it's that sh
it's it's strange to me that you can't
wrap your head around watching something
on a
laptop i don't know yeah
anywhere else yes but in your living
room you should have a television you're
a business owner
you're living like a college kid yeah i
have no i don't have time to watch
if i had a tv then i think of room i
view tvs as a product
it's a waste of production time but
you're watching
you wouldn't yeah when i'm like late
when i'm going to bed or something the
rest of the day i'm on the computer
working all right
yes so while you're watching your big
screen tv with your finger in your
[ __ ]
i'm working to my thumb first of all the
other fingers in my belly button
plug it up airtight i wonder which
smells worse
the belly button ain't good very asiago
asiago cheese deep i'm never going to
look at you the same
were you before but that doesn't make
any sense
i literally don't know how to answer
fellas i just figured out how we catch
the mouse
put it in foley's belly button no we
just have you lay down shirtless in the
living room he's not going to be able to
climb up that
[Laughter]
well he'll make base camp and then take
the summit another mouse another mouse
has to lead him up there a rat leads him
up
a little tiny little north face with
goggles so the other night i'm [ __ ]
laying down
turn back man it's not worth it
all right the mighty cheese isn't worth
it little mouse little goggles on
little guy he's got like frost all over
his whiskers
he's passing other dead frozen mice
[Laughter]
man i like that little mousy
so i'm laying in i'm laying in bed
you're laying on the couch
just got this on your laptop yeah no tv
i'm on my side like this
yeah you know i like doing that nice
little prop up
do you lay down shirtless on the couch
time to time i like to use this
it depends if i'm no it depends if i'm
going to bed depends what time it is
i tend to wear a sleep shirt it's a 90.
something a little more comfortable i
remember i did that for a little while
when i was a kid and my dad put the
kibosh on it real quick or a night well
one of your mom's negligees or something
patty the little one's in the end of the
drawer again
i'm pretty sure i put one of her bras on
when i was a kid i'm listening
for shits and giggles i had my cousin
when they all went over they used to
dress up dressed me up as a girl
like all my mom and my aunt would like
go out to go out to dinner or whatever
and like the older girls were supposed
to watch me
and they come back i was dressed up like
madonna in the 90s hide the big cones
[ __ ] tootsie over here yeah tootsie
weekend
no all my my i was surrounded by
female cousins and they all wore
long t-shirts to bed yeah you know what
i mean how girls do
yeah so i kind of started doing that
alfresco what's al fresco no one
commandy
all flopping around yikes
feeling sexy i think might get your hair
up in a bun
got a set of rollers
i'm yapping on the phone oh i got your
little feet kicking on the bed yeah
crosstalk uh yeah and i think my my dad
saw me one morning wearing it he was
like
you have to put some sweats lose the 90
and the jellies will ya
go put some sweatpants on and shoot a
hundred free throws
yeah my but that happened i i didn't
when my my brother was younger i was
probably like
he was my brother was probably five and
the same thing my sister was older
like six yeah they [ __ ] with you so
but my mom
took them out my sister was like got a
pair of jellies right they were like the
you know the little things you're gonna
[ __ ] tell me bro
so i was at the forefront of women's
fashion
in the 80s and 90s your cousins kept me
in the loop i knew everything that was
going on the toughest response to
jellies that has ever been said
what you got to tell me bro yeah i no
[ __ ] joke
but my br i remember the story of my
brother was my mom got my brother a pair
because he's like he didn't know he just
wanted
like my sister got them so he's like ah
like she got him a pair too
so he my dad came home he was playing in
the driveway and a pair of like pink
jellies
my dad's like you lose them shoot like
that was like
that was he's like i don't give a [ __ ]
what you do door today i ain't coming
home my kid ain't wearing jellies
hey cinderella yeah ah that's good
um um yeah the mouse
so i saw him he [ __ ] scooted across
the hallway
yeah hopping real he's a [ __ ] fast
this guy's got a motor on him
let's get some athletes i don't know if
he's made by sea do or what but this
guy's [ __ ] cooking
what's the sponsorship situation i don't
know i don't know if he's with fox
racing or who but this guy
cooked what's he doing he just [ __ ]
zipped yeah
that wasn't him because i'm trying to
like i'm like about to pass out i can't
pass out with mouse on the brain
will you pass out on the couch i will
yeah yeah yeah and then lumber into the
room at some point
it depends on like what time if i get up
to pee or whatever yeah yeah
okay yeah depends depend also depends
how cold that living room is because
that thing gets
in baby real cold dude that thing's on
62. i like it we put a new one in our
bedroom man
[ __ ] that thing's just all night
yeah [ __ ] big thick blanket on you
the blanket's all cold
ugh sometimes it's tough i wake up i'm
like it's too
cold it's like painful and it's like
artificial air yeah yeah yeah
my sinuses are out of control oh that's
good
boogers for the for the record there's
boogers on his hands
it's not it's different that's not
different that's blood's liquid boogers
dude
yeah liquid boogers yeah it's the same
booger it's like water and ice okay it's
the same thing
no they're two different things no same
made up of the same material same
chemical you just coughed on your other
hand
yeah all right see well i'm not meeting
anybody
hey jesus did i have a dream last night
that somebody wouldn't shake my hand
is it me no no one ever should shake
your hand yeah
if anybody's just watched the last 15
seconds of this episode no one should
ever touch your skin
uh according to the u.n it's illegal to
release you into a war zone yeah
you're like the wuhan factory factory
lab whatever there you go okay get it
right hey
head zip it are you okay you are
whatever i say you are and you're gross
booger head on cm um all right let's
switch gears let's do a couple of
questions so that's it with damascus
he's just there he's just there i got to
take care of the
the dane the lady my lady is like let's
get the humane traps
and i i want to ice this way why not
don't do that look cute little guy
don't get the blue ones the glue ones
are tough plus i don't think you have
the stones to
do what's needed to be done the [ __ ] i
don't i don't know if you do
i have what do you mean i got bodies on
yeah me too man from working at
restaurants i used to hate it
first thing in the morning you come in
heaven in that coffee you [ __ ]
got to do it yeah it's either him or you
you know also then like with the humane
one i'm not like walking to the [ __ ]
park and letting this guy go or whatever
he wouldn't last two seconds out in that
park two seconds rats [ __ ]
the hawks the eagles all that [ __ ] the
owls where are we little house of the
prairies fox eagles i got hawks in
central park
yeah i'm not walking to central park
taking to a local park throw him out the
[ __ ] six story window i don't give a
[ __ ]
get out of my house you think he would
live he threw him out if you threw a
mouse at a six-story window
what that'd be like dropping you off the
entire state building what are you
talking proportionally that's insane
no i thought that would float down no
they don't you know what a mouse is
or six stories do you know what anything
is that
we're currently talking about they're
light they're light they bounce
they bounce hey dahmer what the [ __ ] are
you doing
they look at you when you drown them too
to be perfectly honest i was trying to
think of the dumbest thing i could say
to see if i could get you to believe it
oh okay yeah it would [ __ ]
i mean that's yeah what that's insane
they look at you when they're draining
them
i would maybe drown them in the toilet
oh my kevin don't do that you can't
flush them
not flush them i would drown them and
then throw them out
what the [ __ ] just step on them man step
glue traps gonna be on my foot what are
you talking about now i'm stuck now i
caught myself
dude drown them would you like to be
drowned
no i'm not living in someone else's
apartment what the [ __ ]
i mean if i was sneaking around some
guy's apartment in the middle of night
when his wife sleeping and he caught me
and drowned me
i'd understand he'd have a case
you get what's coming to you i mean hey
you make the bed you sleep in you know
what i mean just let him go
let him go right now he's going to have
babies they can't just have babies by
themselves
he's not going to eat now he's got a new
apartment i think he's not going to
shack up with an opera
he's gonna be pulling tails hey i'm
uptown now dollface
we're gonna one bedroom sunken living
real nice spread
[ __ ] bozo on a couch he don't know
what's going on
i can't even have a tv [ __ ] loser i
tell the squad to come on
up this place is wild this place is this
place is prime for the picking all the
onions you can eat
skit steaks ugh
that's my boss no tv and a [ __ ]
industrial bag of onions
that big commercial burlap sack bag
what's that nutty made out of out
they're making latkes
that's a lot of potatoes
all right we gotta [ __ ] sis things
[ __ ] goofballs
this one's wonky all right guys this is
our you gorpe
let's go quit screwing around that's
really guys that's everybody [ __ ]
sharp shape up here all right
fully pick your nose let's get back on
track all right oh this is a perfect one
this is from chris scott
um guys so as you know when you're doing
the patreon we'll answer your garbage
question
uh this is from chris scott you or
anyone in your family do snot rockets
i'm i mean you do snot everything else
every single day
you do a snot what in the shower in the
shower 100
yeah but sometimes i'll just do it in
this right when i wake up i'm
all jammed up it's like it's like the
conshohocken curve in there it's [ __ ]
pushing this thing again it's tight tell
me cut that
box um i'm all jammed up
so i gotta go right into the into the
sink i stuffed my
head sink the kitchen sink or the
bathroom sink not an animal
i mean you're currently talking about
blowing snot into a sink that your
people brush their teeth at put my face
over the sink i let the water run
and then and then
clean it all off okay get it out so you
know when you wake up you see someone
doing on the street
i'm starting to have a serious problem
with afrin though i bought one because i
was jammed up
and now i notice i'm doing it like every
couple of days your nose literally
becomes addicted to it
thank you i was in the ninth grade i
appreciate that thank you very much
i'm aware that's why i'm telling it to
my friends
that i might have a problem so we got to
send you away or something yeah afro and
rehab
yeah where does that take place i don't
know yeah switzerland somewhere
oh yeah okay
well that's not a company expense what
were you going to say toby
um i forget but
toby and him ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Laughter]
producer of the stars it's getting sharp
i'm great at my job you ever heard of it
called a
[ __ ] farmer's hanky yeah yeah
anything and that's gross yeah farmers
yeah
100 you got to clean that [ __ ] out
oh i remember okay so you know when you
wake up you're like you're like achy
and like and like a normal person makes
like some you know waking up noises
sure can you imagine the grandfather
level kneeling
cooking on him oh my god gotta be bad
you gotta warm her up
yeah yeah thing takes a couple of
[ __ ] things a couple of minutes to
turn over
like a pickup in the winter
[Laughter]
oh it's tough it takes about a good
15 minutes for me to know what's going
on
really yeah yeah i'm pretty good i still
i'm up a cough uh maybe a
hock a luge a pee i'm cooking i'm all
right
there's nothing you don't you like
getting up right away i like
going outside especially in the summer
you get the [ __ ] nice sun
on you some fresh air yeah yeah go get
coffee shout out to starbucks
go out and get a cookie no make coffee
in the house huh like if i can walk i'll
go i like i like [ __ ] starting the
day i like going outside the city's
coming to life a little bit you know
nice in the [ __ ] pharmacies pushing
up the [ __ ]
hey miss camaree good to see you hey
johnny
hey kev how are you yeah how's the
podcast going
pretty good
how what a [ __ ] segway this is from
jamie if you gotta wear equipment to go
to sleep you're garbage
example ace bandages sleep apnea
machines or mouth guards
this guy gearing up for a hockey fight
for fighting relax
did you did you have braces no let me
see
yeah not bad i had this i had i told you
i had that separator the appliance right
where they [ __ ] open up your
skull i was shout out to my orthodontist
that was in his
house what about uh do you ever have to
wear a headgear
headgear is a tough look at night you
have to do it oh that was like the
biggest voice that was a southpaw thing
stopped looking at my head gears right
now i literally
i wore it two nights and i was like
there's no [ __ ] way i'm ever gonna
watch
it now dudes [ __ ] wires hooked up to
your braces did you have braces
yeah i braces for like four years
because i was so bad with them
they would always i'd always break them
pop them [ __ ] this that
hanging off now i hated them
my teeth are still jacked up let me see
oh man
yeah didn't do nothing it's even tough
when you're trying to show your teeth to
see your teeth
well it's just the way my face is built
i got fat lips yeah i was gonna say yeah
yeah
yeah are you looking behind me for it i
was looking at old foley to see if his
lips are fat
he's got big chompers oh man
yeah that's that's garbage but those
sleep apnea machines man i'm still
trying to [ __ ] work it out with my
doc to get into sleep study
i want one of those my pop said it'll
change your life yeah
fresh sleep probably haven't gotten a
good night's sleep in five years
you know yeah i got to get on that but
yeah that's trash
i thought you were doing a sleep study
what's going on with that i'm [ __ ]
waiting to hear back from my doctor
what's going on with his psycho guy too
so
the shrink yeah haven't really matched
with anybody been looking
what do you want tinder what do you mean
[Laughter]
all right let's see this one's just
[ __ ] bonkos to me this is from pat
uh i haven't had a question read yet
ever sharpie a designer brand logo i.e
drawing a swoosh on a plain set of socks
and it had a lot of people on the
patreon liking that which makes me think
other people are doing that drawing your
own swoosh on the socks
or anything although drawing a little
alligator you gotta have a steady hand i
guess
i would be called out immediately it's
upside down
yeah that's that's garbage yeah no also
like
yeah i don't think i need name brand
socks that bad
never go go blind socks blank all day
i've seen someone white out a fourth
stripe on knockoff adidas
like on the shoes really bad look
yeah there's no need for any of that
kids be yourselves don't worry about
that
you're gonna do that listen to uncle
hank um
let's see uh this is a pretty good one
this is from andrew uh when you get
something from a vending machine do you
check to see if the previous person left
any change in the coin return
or do the yeah or that was big on like
i'll look at people pay phone
yeah i saw some lady doing it at a meter
the other day
at a what
yeah like some some [ __ ] street
person no not even a street person just
some old
wasn't a business woman old dirty lady
[ __ ] in astoria
she had a shopping cart checking for
checking for coins
yeah i mean i don't do that now i get it
though i you know i have like
i think like my stepdad will still like
if he sees a payphone he'll like pop in
and look
why some people just like the win they
like
the win yes it's the same thing as like
you know
jumping the turnstile or it's a mental
thing of like if i
i don't care what i look like if i get
caught a win's a win
a win is a win i do check if somebody
leaves a
their receipt form from the atm in the
thing
i always check and see what they got
cooking i started doing that now hey
take a look at it
that's patreon take a look at it i won't
use to see i
should turn around and show the people
online kids ever see each kids ever see
875 hours
38 cents don't check on monday because
it ain't going to be there
this is weekend balance yeah that's a
mid-month flex
oh yeah yeah yeah that's yeah that's
before automatic payments flex
um yeah no i see that too sometimes you
see like these [ __ ] people with like
[ __ ] 15 grand and they're checking
15. i remember i saw somebody had 250
000
in their checking account yeah yeah it
was taking money out of a [ __ ]
at a deli yeah where else is he going i
mean it's like he's got that at the
house
it's crazy yeah i used to think that
once you got to a certain level of rich
you started operating
in like a whole nother world i think you
do
what do you mean he was asking you what
do you mean
what do i mean either i mean i didn't
mean what do i mean
what do either one of you mean what do
you mean they're like you stopped you
stopped using the regular bank and [ __ ]
that it was like chase private yeah
something you know
like you would you wouldn't go to the
local grocery store there'd be some
other upscale
like like high-end secret like bruce
wayne
entrance type deal man you're poor yeah
jesus christ i think there's underground
[ __ ]
food markets no yeah you still gotta get
to i mean everybody has an iphone
regardless if you're a [ __ ] if you're
worth a hundred billion dollars or
[ __ ]
negative a million dollars you still
have an iphone everybody puts their
pants on one leg at a time toby
some are just a little bit hairier fully
does it with a 15-minute break between
getting my socks on the pain in the ass
i'll tell you that really you seem like
a limber guy
oh god hmm
go ahead i'm just trying to figure out
how we monetize a video of you putting
your socks on
at 3 000 patrons i'll do it now
i'll fully try to put on a set of roller
blades
no shoehorn trying to walk in a pair of
skis
[Laughter]
ah man all right let's see here
uh
this is from romero is it classy or
trashy making
ice cubes out of flavored drinks orange
juice cubes for champagne or kool-aid
cubes for the kids
pain yeah i guess if you're doing like
that's pretty good i mean that's the
trashiest way to do a mimosa i think
you freeze the orange juice and then
drop it in the champagne
if you're doing it with which hold on
i'm sorry i always thought mimosas were
classy
mimosas are bottom of the barrel trash
they've become that yeah they've been
because they changed at some point right
in the 90s or 2000s i always just
thought champagne was classy but then
we'd do it on like sundays down the
shore
i'm like we'll be like making pancakes
and they bust out like the three dollar
bottle of champagne and the [ __ ]
tropicana and we go to town
bottle of moots or whatever it's called
brute yeah andre
yeah bottle of andre and they're making
mimosas
yeah we'll do it we'll do a couple of
mimosas i gotta be honest with you
like a little bit a little bit i'm
drinking them out of solo cups yeah
it's tough um i believe the uh
the intelligentsia tried to combat that
by
by introducing the bellini which would
be a little bit more classic what's that
school me on that big prosecco no it's
peach
mimosa orange juice fellini's peach
just peach and champagne pea champagne
or prosecco what is prosecco
prosecco and cava are two sparkling
white wines that's right yeah
champagne is only made in champaign
france everything else is sparkling wine
[ __ ] snapple facts relax okay
um prosecco tends to be a little bit
sweeter kava's more of a
a dry profile you wouldn't really make
mimosas or bellini's with cava you would
make it with prosecco
because there's a little bit more
sweetness to it okay
yeah once anything is available any sort
of bottomless form
sure yeah it really takes a hit to the
bottom line
yeah there's no bottomless black amex
cards going around
it's literally bottomless yeah the whole
purpose of it i mean you're not giving
them away
can't buy them in brunch
i literally don't know what that meant
there was this place it's closed now
closed in during the pandemic uh but it
was uptown
on like 125th street uh it was a big
beer garden out there they had a great
kitchen
and their brunch it was bottomless
anything
so it was bottomless ipas due to me and
my boy gucci
we would go and just literally drink
like [ __ ] 15
and like get carried out of that place
by like 2 p.m
it was a [ __ ] scene yeah i have like
half of a half of an omelette and then
be like puking on the subway
it was [ __ ] tough that's crazy yeah
then they would give it because it was a
beer garden like a so they give you the
big [ __ ]
the big you know how much was the brunch
40 bucks or something
damn they didn't make it huh it was like
i can't believe it they didn't make it
out of brunch dude they didn't they
didn't know what they were up against
i've said it today i've said it before
i've never met an open bar i haven't
beaten
even like an expensive all-inclusive
weekend like week somewhere
what do you mean getting my money
they're they're losing money on me i'm
getting you
two of the time orders i have two at a
time give me a [ __ ]
you know give me like a sex on the beach
with a [ __ ] vodka floater you know
i'm going all out
i'm doing doubles oh yeah i'm getting
you give me a sex on the beach with a
vodka floater with a tequila floater
with the tequila sunrise floater i'm
taking lobsters back to the room i'm
doing everything
if he's walking back to his table with
the blender
i got a power i got a power strip at the
table i'm just running three nutri
bullets
i'm telling you you're not gonna no open
bar has ever been i've always wanted an
open bar
all right you know i've been there's
been a couple of close calls
but i've always feel i've come
victorious walk in with a shot ski and a
beer pong table
ready to [ __ ] go that was big uh
growing up we would
growing up in [ __ ] college you would
like the bars in philly would run like a
20 dollar
or forty dollar two-hour open bar or
whatever
and i mean you gotta go in there and
mean business oh yeah rum and coke
those bartenders really know how to
[ __ ] slow it down too
that's why you know what you do is when
you get there you typically
you drop you drop a dub yeah we didn't
have i mean we didn't have that kind of
cash in college i barely have that cash
now but
what the the rule would be someone get
real estate
someone always had real estate buy the
bar right right so if there was like
eight of us someone was like there was
always one or two people at the bar so
you could sneak in and get there
typically what you want to do to
optimize
your drinking is uh get someone by the
cash register because they always got to
go back to the cash register
people buying drinks and when you're
there hey can i get two more ramen
yeah [ __ ] stick and move we were
[ __ ] savages got operatives
everywhere
yeah have a guy in the kitchen watching
about
i'm telling you you got to get up pretty
early in the morning to beat me baby
gotta do it you weren't a big open bar
guy
where are you what do you mean i don't
know i wasn't a big going to the bar guy
in college or high school yeah never
busy getting swirlies couldn't get out
of my locker
um now in college i didn't really i
wasn't a fan of going to the bars and
stuff like that
yeah about you know the fraternity house
or like a pearl jam and
you [ __ ] you know i was wrapped up
and write poems
wrapped
sunny days sunny day what were the
lyrics to that again
sunny day sunny day sunny day me sunny
day sunny day sunny day you
that was the chorus and that was the
first song i wrote
all right bozo dude writing
did it take you to write it
a couple heartbreaks okay dude we were
in the car the other day driving to the
studio and foley goes this song right
here
ruined my life for four years oh you are
a guy who connects emotion to everything
you know what i mean two songs that damn
yeah
i haven't eaten veal scampi since she
left
her what's the dish that's so close to
it
it was cafe dante it was my birthday and
the dish was
muscle's red couldn't look at a muscle
for three years
loser you now i'm back
now the two songs are psalmy by old 97s
i don't know what any of that means i
haven't heard the song or the i
clearly know it's a song by a band okay
jesus christ and the other one is clay
pigeons by blaze foley
brutal wait clay pigeons by blaze but
sounds
okay it just happened has the same name
as me blaze foley
that you kind of like him because of
that though and if you've never heard
them
save yourself some time they [ __ ]
suck ass that plays fully blaze fully's
top shelf
i doubt it he doesn't know you don't
know either to be fair
suburban mall culture this kid doesn't
know what's going on
oh that's the premise of this entire
show
it's true he's got you there fair enough
uh
foley is like yo this is fully ifolia's
the kind of guy who'll get in the car
like this song
rocks or this [ __ ] this thing kicks and
it's like this [ __ ] obscure
power ballad and you're like what the
[ __ ] pop-pop let's go
put on some with a [ __ ] with some
distortion or something i'm trying to
[ __ ] rock
throwing the baby will you yeah i love
that song right now
what dua lipa and the baby levitating
oh that'll get you going in the club
what would it take
she's beautiful also too i thought for a
patreon thing and i want to get to that
because i keep thinking of and keep
forgetting to text the group or talk
about it with you guys as we should do
a day in wildwood sure go down and do
the beach we could do the [ __ ]
boardwalk
get some footy love it be good love it
family will be down there no i'll make
sure they're not please
no make sure they're not there
what was that i thought she can hang out
okay
you know yeah um i think that'll be good
though intelligent
you want a roller coaster or something i
don't floom no
got a picture of us going over it i
like thomas the train
[Laughter]
uh yeah i wouldn't fit on a roller
coaster i can't fit in a booth
at a diner i wouldn't fit on a roller
coaster yeah you couldn't
fit in an ohio diner booth yeah at a
waffle house
sure shout out to it
he's sliding that booth smothered and
covered
put a little chili on his belly he'll
get in there
rub a little butter on there get him in
there oh my god
this one's just crazy and it's been on
there for a while and i gotta get it is
it crazy or is it
bonkers that's a good one this one's
crazy okay
i don't i mean i'm assuming this uh
josiah
i believe i'm pronouncing that right
j-o-s-i-a-h
sounds good josiah um josiah
um j silence ever have your dad or
grandpa
buy oil dip sticks while camping to
roast hot dogs
so i guess and that's insane to me but
it's been on there a bunch and i want to
get to it when i bend
i don't know the whole the whole thing
is nuts to me buying oil dipsticks yeah
i guess you can go to like an automotive
you can go to like [ __ ] autozone and
buy
dip like a cheap thing of generic
dipsticks and then i get in theory
it's clean metal it's not like jews sure
slip it right in the middle
it makes sense i i we used to do
something worse than that
oh my god coat hanger oh
what that's crazy
one of the nice wooden ones no
steal from a hotel they say armada on it
no it's not bad the foleys are big with
with hangers we've used hangers
for just about everything boosting cars
no we we always use get a hanger but
we've had those things bent 40 different
ways
oh yeah trying to do something and
trying to get this place channel
[Laughter]
i got hangers taped to my dad's head cut
him up on the roof
hey walk to the back take two steps left
i think i see a tip
yeah that's uh that's a tough look i'm
trying to think we had one for something
like a hanger yeah it was like bent
a hanger a hanger you got a hanger steak
nice that that does something weird with
i don't know i mean that guy's bonko's
uh i don't think that's that bad with a
um
a hanger for uh for hot dogs for
grilling but i feel a lot of time that
medal has
is like treated or something yeah
there's a coating on it and then that
starts cooking
that's why the classic garbage line of
you got to burn it off first
any time you gotta burn it off no matter
what it is that's tough
that was big in my family of like with
needles getting like the splinters out
or something we would
i would sit there and torch him torch a
sewing kit until it turned
[ __ ] breath it would be like molten
hot run it underwater and then start
digging
like i'm in the civil war or something
and i just heard a little alcohol on
the same thing now we were fine there
was a in the ryan house hold a lighter
was way more handy than rubbing alcohol
[ __ ] dumping jim beam on it or
something we did my boy
my boy pat we were in we stayed on 12th
street
in north wildwood uh with my family my
boy pat came down
and we were going to the beach and i got
a huge splinter in my foot it was like
this long like on the
walking to the beach like on like a
wooden like boardwalk or whatever
like it hurt dude this it was like
literally like two and a half inches
like
i just it was like a piece of wood not a
splinter like a shard
and i'm like now i'm like 11. i'm
[ __ ] crying they take me back and
they like my stepdad
he always has a cutco knife on him like
a little pocket knife like a cutco
yeah what's cutco cutco's a company have
you ever heard of coco well i have an
excellent investment opportunity like
all nice kitchen knives
[Laughter]
you want to make a little cash uh but he
always has and dude he has like
he's like cut bait with it he'll like
he'll cut like a piece of salami with it
he digs him
dude he dug in my foot i it literally
was like a civil war
operation wait why was he with you and
pat i went back to the house oh
cause i'm like this is a [ __ ]
emergency we gotta go to that and he's
like i got it
dude and i said i remember just him
going to [ __ ] town on my foot with a
pocket knife
with like a chip tip on it it was just
[ __ ] in there
that's a [ __ ] tough look i don't
think he i don't think he sterilized
that either
my mom used to love that stuff whenever
we had anything like that
she was maniacal with it i told you she
used to if we had warts
she would you get warts when you're a
kid we talked about this
i've had one yeah but you said it like
you would you know when we had warts we
get them all the time it seemed
i don't know what we were doing try
apple cider vinegar on it but she'll
she would peel off she would take
tweezers she'd sit there
under the lamp on the couch while she's
watching like moon landing or something
i'd have my you know i'd have to sit
there and hold my finger [ __ ]
marlboro [ __ ] just burn it in the
ashtray and she's
taking tweeze tweezers and peeling off
the top of the
wart to expose the little root
seed cecilia for whatever they're called
they're like little fibers
did you ever see underneath a wart
there's like little little fibers
yeah we can breeze past this yeah and
then she would drop the
the wart remover on there uh get it at
the base level
stung we got it we gotta get it at the
root that would start hurting
that thing
[Laughter]
that would start hurting in the middle
of the night and talk about pain just
searing man no i ripped one off and it
never came back
nice yeah tough guy real tough guy
i cut one out of the bottom of my foot
with a razor blade oh
we've got some on the bottom of their
feet yeah
oh there's toby's got weird feet too oh
my gosh hope he's got maybe the weirdest
hoes i've ever seen that's what you
should post
a video of on for patreon show people
you should do only fans with those
things or
you know [ __ ] ripley's believe it or
not or something those things are
[ __ ]
cuckoo well hands come out like raccoon
bands
dude they're terrible oh god long you
have toes that are as
long as my fingers you definitely have a
toe that's longer than that my big toe's
about that about that yeah
it's flat too it's like a hammerhead
i don't trust it never sleeps either
like a doll's eyes black guy he's like a
doll's eyes
um all right this one's from zach this
is all right for the this is from the
facebook group switch over a little bit
uh it's from the facebook group this is
from zach townsend does your dog have
visible nipples
because if it does i'm out i got to be
honest with you i'm not coming over for
dinner if i can see your dog's nips
that's a thing i'm going out on a limb
here i realize that's not
you know progressive but i don't want to
see your dog's nipples
i would rather see visible nipples on a
dog than
an open butthole open buttholes open
butthole's tough
crop tail yeah just there she is staring
at what happens
that happens though yeah but
nips are tough yeah like because when
you're rubbing when you're
you know when you're trying to pet their
belly
[Laughter]
you don't want to hit i i look no yeah
no
i don't go i don't i don't go on the
undercarriage nope i stay it
i stay at the no yeah you know
yeah i do feel like if you got a dog it
would be like a business partner
yeah you're not you're what
you're not just cuddly i yeah i'm sorry
i'm not with cuddly with you
would you baby talk him night puppy dog
i mean like in
his 18th birthday get him a t-bill
uh yeah you're gonna treat your dog like
a stepdad
call me kevin
he came on um
i'm looking back at the end of my i did
a lot for that dog i did right by that
dog
i don't understand why he's got a
problem with me wasn't my goddamn dog
no yes i yeah of course but also like
you do it to a point that's like
embarrassing
to me as an adult just do it honestly
yeah and i'm honestly it i get it
yeah you turn into like uh you do it
like a spy you're checking the room for
bugs
you'd be like all right we're clear with
your booty yeah yeah i'll do it when no
one's home and the lights are out
don't [ __ ] tell anybody about this
oh of course yeah yeah yeah i love puppy
doggy
and kitty cats yeah that's i mean dude
you're a 45 year old man that's insane
you don't like snuggling puppy dogs and
kitty cats yeah i just
i would never say it's it's so
cringe-worthy t-bone anything on this or
am i out on no man's land no you're
he goes overboard with it thank you
thank you
i do it a little bit with milo homie
though i underst i totally get it and i
should also never i've never seen your
cat
or i haven't seen your cat in your ears
my cat's beautiful though she beautiful
she's a little fate little
okay i am absolutely the cutest cat on
planet earth oh my god i'm done
with two [ __ ] dorks looks like carl
maldon we do have to chill we're gonna
get bullied by the other podcast
oh my god dude we're gonna get [ __ ]
done holy where's your kid we're gonna
get
surprised if we don't get wedgies on the
way out of here [ __ ]
doors god damn holy [ __ ] we got a
reptile upkeep
oh god damn um
uh all right this one's from brett uh
also for the facebook group
uh ordering the burger at a nice seafood
restaurant
[Laughter]
which listen as i've been a very picky
eater my whole life i've hated everybody
judging what i order but
maybe everybody what i don't know if
you're in the mood for a burger get a
burger it shouldn't be on the menu if
you don't want me ordering it it
shouldn't be on the menu at a seafood
place there i go but
it is sometimes the poor the the the
cheapo selection should be
grilled chicken breast i've done that oh
i'm sure you have
yeah are the group chicken breasts will
show it anyways
no starter what enough i don't mind
spending the money i just
i'm a picky eater so if i if i if i get
i
if i get boots on the ground and i don't
i don't like the offense or i don't like
the defense i'll change the [ __ ] play
and go
sashimi you got the sound of that goes
straight up the middle this chicken's
from america right all right i'll take
one of them
um where were we we were somewhere
recently where they had that
they call it like the pub burgers
something like that they always shut i
get it
but you know probably pretty good it's
pop if it's a nice seafood joint
they know their way around the organized
steakhouse you know
yeah steakhouses i mean you know yeah
yeah throw a nice piece of medium
yeah i've been really hungry for a
hamburger i've had a hamburger since
oh i had one in cleveland yep i know
you're hungry for the bun
yeah probably hunger for the bun i like
a good bun know what i'm not a fan of
now i might upset a lot of vegetables no
i love vegetables
i might
[Laughter]
[Music]
i might upset a lot of people out there
but i want to go on record
and say and maybe it's just because i've
never had a great one
but the pretzel bun can hit
the [ __ ] bricks i mean i don't
encounter it that much but
you really don't and people they try to
push it well they do it you get it
something i mean is it like what shaped
as a pretzel
no you like the brioche style pretzel
bun yeah i'm fine with that
i like it brioche it's it's hearty but
brioche is different in a pretzel
i know it's the style i love a brioche
sure fresh a lot of them try to slip the
old ones
yeah get the dales suck kick
yeah can't do it no
can do all right let's see here uh
i feel like hold on i feel like if you
do order that burger if you're out to
dinner with a bunch of people or people
and you order the burger you have to i'm
just gonna get the burger yeah
you gotta say see you can't just order
i'll have the hamburger
people are getting the octopus the
bronzino the [ __ ] muscles the clams
the seafood tower
i'll have that you got you gotta i mean
it's gotta be the re if you're going
because you're like i just wanna spend
the money or whatever
and you're doing it they'd be like oh
let's just give me a nine dollar burger
that's probably pretty it's not a nine
dollar burger no i'm just making i'm
saying if you're i'm trying to make if
you're doing it for the reason to save
money
instead of getting the [ __ ] seafood
tower it's a little trash
i would probably not go if i didn't have
the money to go to be like oh i'm gonna
get what i want
i'm not gonna [ __ ] go sure but at the
same time
if you're going you know what i [ __ ]
walked in i saw the burger the guy next
to me had the burger that looks pretty
good i'm in the mood for a burger i'm
getting a [ __ ] burger
i don't think you have to preface it
with anything i like that just order the
[ __ ] burger i like that i don't
understand why
i thought the preface was the guy next
door had one looked pretty good no i
don't think you need to do that just go
i want the [ __ ]
uh hey guys i'm going to burger this is
coming from a guy who had a life of
having to defend everything
every [ __ ] every decision ever yeah
yeah yeah it's also like
which just bothers me i've never looked
at something like that's what you're
getting like i don't care what you eat
i'm concentrated on me over here chicken
fingers
chicken fingers maybe a nugget maybe a
tender however you got them i want them
oh the chicken fingers tower please
[Laughter]
not the shabby um let's do two
uh do two more and then we'll get out of
here let's do that i have a feeling
i've never done this i have a feeling
toby's going to be very opinionated on
it this is from mike
dude i'll tell you i do it the best
whatever it is toby does the best um
this is from mike davis in the old
facebook group it just says pickleback
shots question mark
say rip ah man he's got pickleback shot
head this guy does
if anybody does pickleback shots it's
[ __ ] tebow mcmuffin toby mcmullen
now i would like to hear a pitch on this
what exactly is it pickle juice
yeah it's a shot of whiskey and then you
follow it with a shot of pickle juice
i'm not opposed to it it's delicious
it's fun i like pickle juice i love
olive juice because i love a nice dirty
martini
filthy nice dirty pair of underwear
like everything's dirty socks underwear
at home here it's it's a novelty shot
it's like milort
it's like a fun thing to do yeah my
thing is it just jams up the [ __ ] jmo
i'm there for the jmo i'm not there for
the pickle well
people have given them timmy and i'm
like get the [ __ ] i'm just doing the
jamison like you gotta do the pickup
though no i just did the jameson and i'm
gonna hang out with these people over
here
they started to do pickle juice as
sports drinks because apparently
it's got a lot of electrolytes in it
yeah they're also pitching milk as a
sports drink
marketing's kooky man i don't know what
who's pitching milk was a sports drink
milk milk baked milk big milk when
recently
that's their whole thing milk does the
body good strong bones
they literally say the original sports
drink yeah they got mark maguire with a
[ __ ] milk mustache meanwhile that
guy's [ __ ]
that guy he's juiced up he's like
tropicana over here
hgh the original sports drink
all right i'd be down for it though ice
cold well i know they're
they're selling like pickled drinks yeah
i was here 30 seconds ago
were you pickleback's fun dude
pickleback's all right more fun than a
lemon drop i'll tell you that much
i don't know nothing's more fun than a
gmo straight up
in and out i mean business if you've
never done one it's worth doing
i know it's not the pic it does there's
nothing selling me on the best part
about a jameson about a pickleback
is the jameson am i right or am i wrong
yeah but does it have to be jameson
no it's just whiskey jim beam whatever
whiskey
old crow i think that's what it is
pickleback is whiskey i guess the flavor
is the combination of the two i guess
but but kev that you're it's like i've
done you know
10 000 whiskey shots why not spice it up
one time
because it does the trick i don't know i
think you'll have to do that on the pod
what a pickle back oh the pickle back
episode i won't out of principle
okay not doing it wait actually i'm
gonna order i'm gonna order the burger
at the [ __ ] seafood no no i got it i
got what the episode is we'll do it on
patreon
and we'll do your city's novelty
booze so like chicago is my lord
i'm sure cincinnati puts like spaghetti
sauce inside of some [ __ ] baileys or
something that'd be a good way to get
[ __ ] up on the podcast
i've been wanting to do a proper
drinking like a proper
drunk episode all right i haven't done
it hit us up with your city's
dumb ass drink yeah and we'll [ __ ] do
it on the patreon yeah yeah
cool cool cool cool um all right let's
do two more things we'll call it
drinking around america
oh man that's i don't like that bob sag
at the hosted
dork um all right this one's from uh
john crawford how long will you go
between washing ice cube trays
which do you ever catch a bad looking
ice cube tray it's got some fuzz in it
maybe like a [ __ ] seed in it or
something
who washes them wash them yeah you wash
them
you're supposed to i've never once in my
life
ever washed an ice tray yeah jesus well
you gotta think like yeah i mean like
it just picks up you know whatever dust
or the crumb
anything just anything i mean you rinse
it off when you're kind of filling it up
not enough not enough really yeah i
think you should be
washing them wow i've seen dirt you see
you could now picture yours in your head
you're like it's a little dirty yeah
there's a fingerprint on it there's you
know a little bit of barbecue sauce or
something
that's on there on purpose yeah barbecue
pops
uh yeah you gotta you gotta do that also
now somebody else's question i forget
the [ __ ] name
uh was well if you have an ice cube
maker
we got one at my parents and it sucks
the ice cube maker yeah
there's some this fridge is whack that
they got yeah
uh but will you put your hand in to take
it god damn right now
i'm [ __ ] waiting all day like a jerk
goof
yeah i don't like those those the the
fridge makes them
uh ice cubes they're like they're like
long and thin and
the crescents not a fan they always
taste
real like coleslaw here they have like
that's just a foliage
oh that's the point yeah maybe give it
more than a rinse
no you're saying the maker yeah
no no no good my my my rent's got a new
fridge a couple of like two three years
ago
uh maybe whatever it was but the old one
had a distinct
that was from when they moved into the
house probably [ __ ] 30 years ago so
it was like probably 28
30 years old when they replace it and
that has a dis
distinct ice cube and water taste yeah
it was like an old [ __ ] whirlpool
appliance yeah that's you know the pipes
of just whatever yeah
they ran its course and it had its own
acquired taste yeah it's not good
also someone else's question when you
drop an ice cube
what do you do you kick it under the
[ __ ] dick only one move
yeah it's kicking into no man's land
that's international waters under the
under the fridge as long as it's in the
general direction of the dog
you've done your part oh yeah yeah if
you got a dog yeah yeah
whatever they decide to do with it
that's between them and the ice cube
yeah
hey i gave the dog an ice cube i washed
my hands of that yeah
um get me kicking his dog ice cube
have fun you're my
best friend lose the nipples
if no no way i would ever i would i
wouldn't be you're not going to get a
female dog because of the nips
really i don't want to roll the i don't
want to fall in love with an animal and
all of a sudden i gotta hate her
what a sicko next thing you know i got
this [ __ ] octomom walking around
i don't need all those nips in my house
[ __ ]
i run a family program dog looks like a
boxing gym just covered in speed bags
um all right then we'll get out this
one's just a [ __ ] home run this is
from
this is from jeremy uh do you swing
directly from the pepto-bismol bottle
hell yeah oh that's
the street directly from everybody
listerine pepto just get southern all
this
and speak directly from every bottle
down there
yeah listerine i mean if you're pouring
it into the cap of a list
i mean you're a [ __ ] jerk-off you
know listerine's grip you know what's
nice every once in a while
nice bottle of scope i'm a listerine man
i like the burns scope's delicious i
used to drink a little bit of it when i
was a kid
like that spearmint flavor i mean that
little peroxide [ __ ] yep
that's some of your mom's deodorant you
know regular johnson and johnson over
here
gang this has been a fun-filled family
episode we love you guys very much
can't be anything you want to tell them
out there yeah we [ __ ] love you guys
thanks so much for the support
uh i'm at kevin rank comedy on all
social media
and uh yeah check out ayg on all social
media
patreon youtube itunes the whole nine
yards we [ __ ] appreciate all the
support
beautiful we love you guys and we'll see
you next week peace